es una tristeza conocer la muerte de
Victoria Melina sabíamos que estaba muy
grave en el momento que fue el ataque
ella fue impactada por un metal en la
parte de atrás de su cabeza y cuando ya
la recogieron los voluntarios que
actuaron inmediatamente es increíble ver
como ayudan y la capacidad que tienen de
redacción en Ucrania pues no pudieron
salvarla y pasar después de días en
cuidados intensivos murió y el legado de
Victoria no es solamente la el de una
gran escritora sino una persona
absolutamente comprometida con su país y
especialmente con Investigar los
crímenes de guerra ella llevaba desde la
invasión a gran escala dejando su vida
personal y su vida también artística
como escritora más o menos a un lado
para dedicarse a ser parte de algunas
organizaciones que investigaban crímenes
de guerra pero antes de esta invasión a
gran escala ya cuando estaba la otra
invasión que comenzó en el 2014 ella se
sentía muy unida al Don Baz
especialmente una pequeña población
llamada New York que había creado un
festival literario allí en el 2021 había
logrado llevar a decenas de escritores
ucranianos hasta allí Muy cerca del
frente de la guerra y hasta allí la
acompañamos hace pocas semanas a que
recorriera esos pasos que era uno de sus
sueños lastimosamente el centro cultural
donde había sido ese ese festival fue
destruido semanas después de nuestra
visita